thinking of mom and dad not being here
during certain life events until I know
that they're going to be there yeah I
can't get married I can't have a kid
Savannah Chrisley vowing to put some
Milestones on hold for a long time we
made that commitment I know I made that
commitment that no matter how tough
things were I was not going to walk away
less than three weeks before her parents
taught and Julie head to prison the
Chrisley Knows Best star gets candid on
her unlocked podcast
business-wise like I keep pushing
forward but personally
I feel like there's a level of guilt
associated with like moving on with my
life thinking of mom and dad not being
here during certain life events in my
mind I'm like I can't move on with my
life if only people knew the things that
they did for people on a day-to-day
basis they're the two most giving people
I think I've ever met my entire life in
June Savannah's parents were convicted
of bank fraud and tax evasion Todd was
sentenced to 12 years in prison and
Julie seven years what we will not do is
we will not break now when it comes to
Life's Precious Moments Savannah says
mom and dad are worth the wait until I
know that they're going to be there yeah
I can't get married I can't have a kid I
can't which
for me like they're gonna eventually one
day get to be a part of it and dad has
told me like when I start feeling bad
for myself dad was like I may not be
here in front of you he was like but I'm
still alive yeah I'm still fighting I'm
still you know you don't have to live a
day without speaking to me exactly and
that Echoes what Todd expressed on his
and Julie's podcast last week
yes what we're going through this storm
that we're going through
it's bad it's tough It's hard it's
hurtful and it and would it be as hard
if the truth was out there no it's
devastating for our family but I had to
look at my kids and say snap out of it
it could be worse God didn't bring us
this far to drop us off with 2023
approaching the family's in for a lot of
changes in the New Year we're going to
Florida it's pastel season not exactly
this time the Florida trip means
reporting to prison to begin their
sentences on January 17th we signed up
for a show that has entertained millions
of people but in the meantime the
Chrisleys have high hopes for their
future on reality TV we're in a much
better place
um you know with new show content that's
going to be coming out that's going to
be giving you a whole new perspective of
the Chrisley family and you are gonna
you are going to get to go through the
ups and the downs and and everything
that we're going through the documentary
that's being that we're working on right
now is going to be very Talent I'm
in the end the truth
may get harder before it gets easier but
we have faith
[Music]